j'aime chanter pour faire le fou j'ai
envie de faire rire les gens première si
j'ai une mission c'est ça à travers la
chanson limitation où les blagues Jean
la pointe adore être devant le public
tout jeune il imite le chancelier Félix
Leclerc à 12 ans il passe un concours
amateur à Québec mais c'est en 1955 en
formant les girola avec Jérôme Lemay qui
lance sa carrière car la seule chose qui
compte vraiment maintenant c'est de
pouvoir posséder un peu d'argent ils
écrivent et composent leur chanson et on
enregistre de très nombreuses le humour
leur fantaisie en font un duo très
populaire au Québec et ailleurs il passe
à la télévision américaine au headshow
et à Paris il monte à deux reprises sur
la scène de l'Olympia
tout se succès cette vie de tournée a un
prix genre la pointe a un problème
d'alcool et sa carrière en souffre quand
j'ai commencé à faire du cabaret j'ai
commencé à prendre un verre et tout ça
je suis devenu un être vraiment
ignoble par moments cruel et
irresponsable après 19 années de succès
les girolas se séparent il faut dire
aussi que Jean Lapointe est de plus en
plus sollicité comme acteur
pourquoi par exemple que je tendrais
dans sa cellule au cinéma il joue dans
les ordres dans l'eau chaude l'eau
fraite dans jmartin photographe entre
autres une belle boule et à la
télévision il incarne le rôle titre dans
la série du Plessis
c'est pour ce qu'on se dit on va laisser
ça la palme
sur scène il entreprend une carrière
solo et renoue avec le succès il
enregistre une vingtaine d'albums dont
le célèbre chante là ta chanson
[Musique]
invité par Raymond Devos au théâtre
Bobino il triomphe à Paris mais il n'a
pas oublié ce que sa maladie lui a coûté
en 1982 il fonde la Maison Jean Lapointe
qui offre des thérapies aux alcooliques
il profite de sa nomination au Sénat
canadien en 2001 pour combattre une
autre dépendance il s'attaque à la
prolifération des appareils de loterie
vidéo
plus tard alors que la marijuana
s'apprête à être légalisée il prône une
intervention auprès des jeunes pour
empêcher la toxicomanie
si on ne supporte pas au niveau de la
prévention
parler de moi après sa retraite du Sénat
il remonte sur scène à 76 ans au côté de
son complice des débuts Jérôme Lemay qui
mourra avant la fin de la tournée
[Musique]
au cours de sa longue carrière Jean
Lapointe a reçu de nombreux hommages à
Québec et à Ottawa et autant dans le
milieu du cinéma et de l'humour que dans
celui de la musique
mes chansons
Geneviève Hasselin Radio-Canada Montréal
imitations ma folie
[Musique]